sur les 900 amendements à étudier
jusqu'à mardi environ 250 ont été
examinées a depuis ce matin ici même à
l'assemblée nationale l'article 21
principal point d'achoppement de ce
projet de loi a été adoptée sur les 103
suffrages exprimés 78 ont voté pour 25
contre en présence de jean michel
blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
a déposé à lui-même cet amendement ce
matin pour rappel cet article restreint
l'instruction en famille et il concerne
quelque soixante deux mille élèves en
france visés par 384 amendement un
record sur l'ensemble du texte
il a été adopté après de longues
tractations si la loi votée mardi une
déclaration ne suffira plus pour pouvoir
enseigner à domicile il faudra désormais
une autorisation le gouvernement a tenté
de désamorcer les critiques en proposant
une période de transition jusqu'à 2024
en tout cas à ce projet de loi a suscité
de nombreux débats ici même au sein de
l'hémicycle mais également dans les
médias dernier exemple en date entre
gérald darmanin et marine le pen hier
soir sur france 2 la présidente du
rassemblement national n'a pas hésité à
tacler le ministre de l'intérieur sur
les nombreux manquements que comporte ce
projet de loi écoutez je suis déçu je
m'attendais à une grande loi de combat
et nous avons à faire un texte de police
administrative vous vous êtes attaqués à
toutes les religions alors que ce n'est
pas un problème religieux l'islamisme
c'est un problème d'idéologie l'islam
le radical dans le viseur de marine le
pen gérald darmanin s et a défendu en
affirmant que la france ne voulait pas
faire de différence entre les cultes les
dispositions que nous mettons dans ce
texte vise à renforcer la loi de 1905
qui est une grande loi de liberté
les députés qui ont encore beaucoup de
travail jusqu'à mardi pour examiner les
derniers amendements et la dernière
séance aujourd'hui aura lieu à 21h et
pourrait durer jusqu'à très tard dans la
nuit pour pouvoir opérer le vote
solennellement mardi prochain